d'entreprise je les crée en début avril
pourquoi c'est vrai que la céramique
j'ai toujours eu un amour particulier
pour la céramique sortant d'un métier
qui était quand même beaucoup plus
difficile parce que antérieurement je
m'occupais de personnes âgées
handicapées pendant plus de 25 ans
les motivations pour créer une
entreprise parce que tout simplement
j'arrive dans la cinquantaine et j'avais
envie d'évoluer par moi même à travers
un travail créé par mes soins et ne plus
être dans l'ombre de mon mari ou être
dans l'ombre de qui que ce soit
l'important c'était ça quand on nous ce
type d'entreprise de l'entourage est
primordial que ce soit les amis la
famille c'est vraiment une entreprise
commune s'est pas je décide de faire la
céramique c'est tout le monde s'y met
les maris sont au feu dévoilant les
mamelles même qui à 81 2 ans elle a
envie de 10 participer ça sa bio permet
aussi de voir autre chose
je suis fière d'elle week d'un lit
passion qu'elle qu'elle en fasse son
métier à l'heure actuelle fabienne avec
un simple objet du quotidien
on a oublié dans le fond du jardin à
rire à le transformer à lui donner une
seconde vie
quand on a de la terre dans ses mains ça
me permet l'évasion
ça me permet de me libérer du stress de
la journée du stress des enfants du
stress de la vie courante au pas de
stress du tout
c'est vraiment une liberté totale parce
qu'on part d'une boule et on peut se
permettre de créer ce qu'on a envie on
peut se dire que voilà je peux faire une
pause je peux faire un éléphant je peux
faire ce que j'ai envie et c'est un
franchement c'est complètement
libérateur
non
le challenge des créateurs pourquoi
parce que c'est une étape supplémentaire
c'est tout simplement comme j'ai sauté à
pieds joints dedans voilà pour moi c'est
une étape supplémentaire
c'est bien sûr c'est c'est aussi avoir
une aide donc pouvoir partie avait à
l'extérieur parce que la réunion c'est
super on y est vraiment très bien mais
aussi voilà on est quand même ouvert
vers l'extérieur que ce soit aux îles
voisines ou voir la métropole ou
pourquoi pas plus loin
cette création d'entreprise de changer
ma vie oui ça c'est sûr l'assurance je
prends de l'assurance à c'est super
important parce que je me dis voilà j'ai
pas fait d'études qui était très longue
on se dit quand on n'a pas fait d'études
comme peut rien faire donc c'est faux on
peut tout faire à condition de le
vouloir et d'en prendre conscience
lancez vous faites des choses parce que
franchement créer quelque chose c'est
super et on est tous capables de le
faire